et samuel le bihan merci d'être avec
nous ce soir vous dans la vie vous êtes
vous êtes aimés c'est pas une illusion
c'est pas de béraut domaine souvent vous
adore non mais les gens que j'aime même
ouais c'est un succès fou moi je n'en
sais rien toutefois si l'agent jimmy à
30 ans à seulement toutes mes copines me
dise comme dans la merde pas du tout
toutes mes copines me disent que je
baisse mon beau père aimerait bien être
avec vous que vous les séduisent et
beaucoup qu'est ce qu'elle dit
au delà
est-ce qu'elle n'est pas jalouse c'est
non ah non non c'est une femme
formidable
alors c'est pas d'année à l'aube aux
autres samuel vous avez déclaré je sais
que c'est le début de notre carrière
mais j'ai du mal à résister à une fille
qui me demande quelque chose en faisant
les yeux doux
moi c'est fini c'est faux manifestement
serge vraiment fidèle alors quand il est
devenu star j'ai bien profité de votre
succès non je n'y vais dire profité non
non non les restos cher les boîtes donné
un bon je vis du temps à rattraper
on a toujours envie de profiter de deux
des choses que qui passe
d'habitude avec les bases de la femis et
de fléchin tout ça non me l'a dit le
bihan une formidable certains coachs
pour réussir
moi j'ai réussi pour coucher c'est pas
con voilà donc au moins je montais pas
un jeu c'est vrai on va voir ce que vous
seriez prêt ou pas à faire par amour
samuel le bihan est ce que l'on fait
peur en chaîne lui alors savez le bihan
est ce que par amour vous seriez prêt à
mettre une perruque blonde
ah ouais ouais ouais pas un bon bien sûr
gagner la maman nous la météo l'a déjà
demandé une perruque
mais est-ce que par amour vous soyez
prêts
arrêtez cinéma du jour au lendemain ah
ouais mais est-ce que par amour ou
seriez prêt à vous convertir à une autre
religion
ouais la finance par amour vous soyez
prêt à cacher quelqu'un qu'elle vient de
tuer ont même tué quelqu'un qui vient de
cacher
et là potage tapoter est-ce que par
amour vous seriez prêt à vous remettre à
la drogue
la passage cette odeur
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prêt en
brasse et 100 fois les chaussettes sales
de daniela c'est la question faut-il le
courreau oui alors on a beaucoup parlé
n'est pas la corne donc non ah bon
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prêt à
vous faire refaire le nez
ah ouais en plus grand emprunt seul le
bien on rentre dans un certain nombre de
questions auxquelles vous avez du mal à
répondre aux havrais est ce que par
amour ou seriez prêts à accepter
quelques infidélités
bien sûr
parce que tu m'as pas demander si c'est
avec un homme une femme non j'ai vu à la
question et je pèse bien plus est par
amour ou seriez prêt à accepter que
daniela est un amant prince richard et
chiant parce que ça vachement moins
drôle vraiment ouais faut c'est une
langue ou alain chabat est ce que est ce
que vous seriez prêt par amour aller
dans un club échangiste avec des timbres
des diggers panini rentrée tout voir je
participe ou non pas pour partie je vais
peut-être déjà fait non non parce que
c'est glauque c'est du cul triste ouais
les portes et jamais devenu une soirée
carlos
le chinois est ce que par amour
vous seriez prêt à devenir l'esclave
sexuelle de daniela je suis déjà à son
école est-ce que par
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prêt je
suis appelé c'est mieux de venir à
changer de sexe non un titre échangé de
fait vous seriez le maître mot shoah ou
alors pas du tout c'est marrant ça je
connaissais pas du tout
laetitia